[Music]
hey guys I'm in the kitchen again what
just kidding okay so I'm so happy that
you guys loved my last baking video when
I made pumpkin cheesecake I am so happy
that some of you guys actually tried the
recipe you guys send me photos and you
were telling me how amazing it was and
so that just made me feel so proud but
I'm so excited to be trying to bake
something new today so today I'm going
to be making pumpkin oatmeal raisin
cookies which I'm sure you already know
because it's in the title but anyway
we're gonna attempt to continue this
pumpkin theme since we're still in fall
and I love pumpkin everything and it's
just the appropriate time of the year to
be making pumpkin everything but I did
get some messages from some of you guys
saying they weren't able to open the
link in the description to get the
recipe or whatever so you know what just
to make things easier just follow my
video if you want to make this video so
we can make it together and it's like
you know a bonding experience between
the two of us well more for you because
I wouldn't know that you're watching
yeah I'm so excited to be doing these
cookies I just love oatmeal everything
we mentioned it when we were in Vegas
and our Vegas vlog how Casey and I love
oatmeal raisin cookies and it's just so
weird that a lot of people think that
they're like grandma
cookies or that they're ugly or like
gross or like whatever I don't care
they're amazing they're delicious I love
them I'm gonna be attempting this recipe
and just cause your fingers for me that
everything turns out all right layer 2
has that terrific game yay I know you
guys said it's easier to work with the
ingredients our room temperature so I
took out the butter and then the
leftover pumpkin stuff that I had from
before so it's been sitting here
hopefully that's okay once again just to
remind you guys I don't know
what I'm doing I'm learning as I'm going
okay preheat oven to 350 here we go
next we need two cups of flour are you
excited I'm making some oatmeal raisin
sissies more excited than pumpkin Oh
Sees anytime okay one cup
Oh what is the third cup of oats so
staring at my cookie we're late my
fountain is not running oh yeah we
actually turn off the fountain for audio
purposes sorry though otherwise it
sounds like someone's peeing in the
background I like to clean up as I go
that's smart cuz I don't and I get new
hard to clean after heard you make such
a big baking soda it's one teaspoon of
baking soda cinnamon we need one
teaspoon of ground cinnamon oh my
goodness that smells good next is half a
teaspoon of salt gotta balance out the
sweet little bit of sodium Oh rice grain
fill in there I put rice grains in here
just to like break up the salt so it
doesn't clump up to learn that from my
grandma and then it says mix it all up
such a mom now this is definitely like a
very mom centric activity now you know I
actually wanted to do these cookies ooh
the ovens ready I wanted to make these
cookies with Isaac but today he's in
school right now and so like you know
what I think you would appreciate it if
I just had them ready but I'm surprised
I'm from school remember how cute you
was if you tried the tooth cake in those
already all done and then you fell on
the floor you loved it so much so let's
see what his reaction is this temper Oh
meal simpie on the ceiling this time
[Music]
today he had a rough day man he's like
super afraid of needles and I had to
take them to go get his blood drawn and
he got like a tipi test which is when
they give you a shot in a couple days
that's taken back so they can read it
but today he was just like he was so
scared oh my Isaac relax it's okay
calm down just breathe just focus in
this moment right now right now we're in
the car you don't have to worry about
anything else in the world all you have
to worry about is just sitting in this
car right now that's I just kept like
walking you through the whole process up
until that moment he's like but what am
I gonna be thinking about when they're
giving me this shot I'm like Isaac it's
gonna be so fast by the time you
register it it's already the times gonna
be gone already so don't even worry
about it yeah he did such a good job oh
so proud of him I'm like I'm proud of
you dude you did it see it wasn't that
bad but then afterwards it was so funny
because we were in the car you wanted to
drink some water but you're just like
I can't drink it mommy I like you are so
exaggerating what inaccurate because he
got his TV tests on one arm and then you
guys blood drawn on the other arm you
just like yes or both arms he's a brave
little boy more brave than he used to be
because there was one time when you had
to get shot - he bit me carrot he was
like crazy thank goodness were over that
okay anyway I've been making this
forever we gotta beat butter brown sugar
and granulated sugar two sticks of
butter I am so shocked and this is how
much butter
these cookies need this is a lot of
butter no wonder they say these aren't
healthy technically this right here so
far hasn't been that unhealthy issues
Tamotsu carbs
here comes the fat and the sugar and
then I need 1 cup of packed brown sugar
oh oh oh
ticking that's brockhard you should have
got some new brown sugar they look like
rocks
[Music]
this is the heart how old this brown
sugar does it expired as brown sugar why
are we done let's not find out
okay hopefully you guys aren't suffering
while you're making your cookies
everyone else at homes like we got fresh
brown sugar the butters like that was a
struggle but we got the brown sugar look
how pretty
next is recognition dance two cups of
sugar this is easier you see I don't
have to work for this one sugar it's so
pretty how it sparkles
[Music]
here we go
I'm never singing why I don't know yeah
I throw in the parade the parade the
pumpkin parade pumpkin parade puree
seeing it we're gonna throw up in the
other can oh yeah sure
where we going actually I don't got you
where are we so fairly need any you know
that means we need to make more pumpkin
stuff now we're gonna have all this
pumpkin stuff left over make a pumpkin
cake mix for my birthday make my own
birthday cake yeah that'd be so awesome
that means I don't have to do anything
yeah my birthday cake last year I did
where'd you get it from same place you
get my birthday cake we got to the damn
place yeah I reorder different cakes to
get the rest let just for me and I get
in there like just come with us
Oh walnuts no is it because yeah I
thought there were pecans now you're
making me doubt myself hey Google what
is nuez and Spanish me nuts hey Google
how do you say pecan and Spanish hey
Google how do you say walnut and Spanish
noise oh you were right thank you you're
right one cup of pumpkin looks like
Thanksgiving that looks like turkey
stuffing yams with the egg and mashed
potatoes extract 1 teaspoon of vanilla
I think you use the other thing now the
feeder no too scared of that thing why
cuz there's legs around everywhere
that's how we made the cheesecake I
looked at my shirt and it was just
cheesecake batter all over my shirt
delicious maybe I should wear some apron
you know a pure apron well I was over
there I think pull it up oh you know
ever since we put the baking video out
everyone's been saying you should make
too thin case aprons that'd be cute I
think no one ever said that to me
whenever I was making cooking videos she
makes one baking video oh you should
merchandise your stuff now hater oh all
right so now that we got this it says
add flour and mix well
[Music]
that didn't happen okay so this seems
like it's good enough now for the
raisins and the walnuts so we need to
add 3/4 cup of chopped walnuts and 3/4
cup of raisins
nuez keep on running in my face I didn't
say raisins as many Google how do you
say raisins in Spanish fast nice pasta
that's true I see I knew that one and
you know in the same way oh there's my
Chinese what I thought I'd do like 50%
of and the peak of my Chinese no EJ's is
now probably doing will dent like 10 my
mouth muscles don't say it no more and I
can't even think of those words that's
fast anymore terrible yeah like I went
ahead for a weekend recently it was so
frustrating I was struggling so hard to
communicate with my family I kept
forgetting how to say certain words or
like I would doubt myself like is that
how you say that word it was the most
frustrating thing to try to have a
conversation with my family cuz I'm like
oh my goodness I haven't spoken Spanish
in like 2 years at all like period Gio
and I we tried to crack
Spanish sometimes but because we're
always around a lot of English speakers
we don't want to be rude and like just
have a full-on conversation in front of
other people that can't understand it so
for most of the time we've never even
practiced well we never even practice
our Spanish sure you chop these into
smaller pieces huh dang it it does it's
Chuck you see you distracted me sorry
oh my god
like you know what this recipe was just
like some failure after failure first
with the brown sugar and then now with
these walnuts yeah so that cutie over
there behind the camera check this week
and then I realized that I chopped these
walnuts until you run it up so thank you
I just thought they're kind of big the
pieces are really really good too I
didn't think about that so even though
I'm blaming you for the reason why I
forgot to do this you were the reason
why I remembered too okay we got these
walnuts out okay now I'm gonna put these
walnuts and
and then crush up all right now they're
all man they're still pretty chunky
whatever chunky walnut bites so if
you're doing this at home what should
they do first I hope what you guys do is
watch this whole video first learn from
my mistakes and then trying it to your
own cookies yeah now we get thrown in
the raisin 3/4 cup of raisins and it
doesn't say cha cha hastin
all right now we have this mixture nice
and done and then now it says drop
rounded tablespoons on to prepared
baking sheets prepare the baking sheet
nice and buttered rounded tablespoons
here we go oh these are coming alive all
right that's cute
here are the cookie this feels so good
and I'm so sorry that you can't try
these cookies yourselves guys watch them
all right it's nice and toasty in there
all right so they're gonna go in the
oven at 350 degrees for 15 minutes
awesome and then you have to go sorry
peace out yeah whoo the timer just went
off the cookies are done and they smell
amazing oh yeah look at that pumpkin
oatmeal raisin cookies oh my goodness
let's eat let's do the toothpick method
yep they're done I'm gonna keep the oven
on for the next batch of cookies cuz I
got a ton of batter in here the recipe
says to leave these sitting for two
minutes and then they can cool down for
the rest of the time on these wire racks
that we have I mean these are the only
ones we have but they should do they
smell amazing so I turn the fountain
back hot pepper flakes almost being in
the background all right so I let a
couple minutes pass by now I'm just so
excited I I just have to try this cookie
i buttered this up really well look at
that way right off oh it smells so good
[Music]
these are good you're doing really good
like the perfect consistency new shock
and moist and the oatmeal pumpkin raisin
walnut flavor is strong I hope the boys
like it too now we're to take the rest
of the cookies I make and I'm gonna take
them to JK news tomorrow because I'm
filming tomorrow and see how everybody
else likes it too um all that effort was
worth it all right you have to turn out
to Ethan Hawke alright so the boys are
home like we just finished having dinner
you know what we say it for dessert it
smell good oh hey I think let me know
what you guys think about you still the
cookie from the cookie jar
[Music]
let me know let me know let me know did
I do a good job
looks like Isaac didn't like it hmm
oh he did like yeah do you like it that
was awesome
yay gingerbread high five I know right
the consistency is really good
interesting what do you think about the
flavor well I thought their gingerbread
I missed it were you do you think you're
not like too sweet you know how they
when you buy into some sweets and
there's just too sweet you know I also
went by cookie you want to buy a cake I
could eat Kennedy's this is really good
oh well I bet you guys like the cookies
cuz when I first tried it I do feel like
the cinnamon might have brought a little
bit too much like there's some sort of
like spicy kick to it but we put very
little so I don't know what it could be
maybe it's the brown sugar your trip
isn't perfect I guess my taste buds
don't work but anyway I hope you guys
make your own pokken oatmeal raisin
cookies and send me photos again because
I love that just totally made my day
leave in the comments what I should make
next I know a lot of you
said I should make those Lich's I'm
definitely gonna try to make that in the
future Ygritte
yeah it's his favorite cake I first sure
want to try to make that are you
activated her who's uh I messed up the
question okay
check out this activator radio mix on
google play music no stop
[Music]